les sous sols de l'uqam cachent des
trésors inestimables
des livres précieux anciens dont
certains datent du xiiie siècle
c'est non seulement un trésor en valeur
marchande mais c'est un trésor en valeur
de contenu la collection compte 18 mai
livres anciens publié avant 1850 dont
l'encyclopédie de diderot ou encore les
oeuvres d'hérodote dans une édition dont
il n'existe que six exemplaires dans le
monde
on peut même y admirer des livres qui
autrefois vous mener à la confesse en
général les meilleurs étaient mis à
l'index sur le résumé mais il y avait
une façon de contourner ça avec le temps
et on le voit dans le l'édition de 554
des colloques les jésuites l'avait dans
leur collection
mais ils ont mis l'étiquette en faire
sur deux lieux
tenez breux qui étaient réservées soit
aux professeurs aux personnes autorisées
l'université a hérité de ses ouvrages à
sa fondation en 1969
c'est un legs du collège sainte-marie de
l'école normale jacques cartier et de
l'école des beaux-arts de montréal qui
ont fusionné pour devenir l'ucap le
collège sainte marie était vraiment
orienté vers l'éducation vers la
rhétorique alors les textes classiques
l'école normale de quartier étaient plus
on sent tendance vers le récit de voyage
alors le nouveau monde
l'école des beaux-arts bien sûr c'est
tout l'aspect visuel les livres de
gravures
seules trois personnes ont la clé pour
accéder à ces précieux manuscrits pour
souligner les 50 ans de l'uqam le public
put actuellement contempler une centaine
de livres qui racontent 500 ans
d'édition ici n'est bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal